collins on the handoff troy gives it
back
for john collins
take a look at this lob right on time
and right on target
and john collins knows how to finish
13-5
atlantis spurt batoon gets it to the man
kemper with three kempa driving blocked
by collins
the horde sounds of the ball game is
over and the
losing streak is gone
beautiful set up off the dribble but
there's john collins
one thing he got too deep he had a
chance to pass the ball to
lamb in the left corner
didn't give the ball up i'm sorry kemba
you did not get involved here with the
andre
that block came first
a good block clean play and the hawks
celebrate
76-58
collins guides it in and gets fouled a
perfect
pass and collins right there to one hand
at home
you know paul george you're getting this
off a little foul trouble
peppery jump stops pass to the corner
anderson
[Applause]
from the raptors talk about five
incredible points that
is amazing for the season tonight
collins to be
lob to john and one hands at home lot
undone by
john collins that's his specialty
herder with a long lead to collins and
john
puts it in and a late whistle for foul
on joe harris
and he gets an easy look
that's seven first quarter points for
jeff coming around with jc
chandler chases him out to mid floor
kevin with five
four on the shot clock they get it to
college turn around oh
john collins and the hawks go up to
123 to 121.
good defense on kevin herter closed out
there by chandler
but john collins nice little dribble
step back
muscle didn't want to foul he burns them
good inside bounce pass here by kevin
early
will that be the game winner
we say goodbye to brooke lopez on six
fouls
uh brookie there's a lot of contact
there my man that's a good call by the
rebs
john collins takes the bump right there
and that finishes at the rim
that's a good call tipped away but into
the hands of trey
back to collins and one hands at home
my goodness that's that's insane
deadman's hit those two threes but he is
going to be gone for a while and there's
the one hander to john collins
the veterinary point guard 31 year old
dj augustine
driving
what a block by john collins
it's just a heck of a block shot here he
didn't see john collins
and the speedster the self-proclaimed
fastest player in the nba
darren fox oh baby oh john
collins taking it around he's my sleep
in the dunk contest man i'm telling you
let's take another look at that dunk by
john collins
here's a wild stat about john collins
he's one of nine players in the nba to
average 19 and nine
and that's ten points right now for
jason tatum
add a steal to that as the aaron fox
comes away with it
collins cross all over luca off the
backboard and slam it home you better
call omar
because that one's gonna be on house of
highlights
as usa has built a 10-point lead one
more time for your mind
he's staring at it and lucas got nothing
mountain dew ice rising stars challenge
maybe the usc team needs an answer oh
some people
this is getting away from the usa team
right now
that's let's take another look from trey
young
spin around john collins man
that is athleticism reggie jackson
29 points seven assists bounce to
drummond
taking it up and collins denies him
by john collins right here on drummond
trey surveys the double screen
[Applause]
wow this gets them out of their seats at
state farm
man what a play that rose wouldn't give
the air space
trey on the lob to collins for the jam
i mean you got to know that john collins
is going to pick and roll
[Applause]
kevin off the two screens he winds up
and throws it down
beautiful dunk but look at the setup by
kevin pinpoint pass
he goes up and winds it up and throws it
down well that brought me out my seat
and on the scale of one to ten this dog
here ten and a half
check out the cash
[Applause]
rebound frazier jonathan open
cutting
[Applause]
that was just a flat rejection yeah that
was a great block look at this block
here by john collins
you should have just laid this up you
know he had time to [ __ ] it back and
thought that john wasn't going to
challenge
that's an easy block for john trey doing
a good job setting them up that's a wide
open three
nice speed blocked by collins
goodness get this block on dj wilson
oh he's got plenty of time only one year
of college he's the point guard he's
gonna have the ball in his hands a lot
you bet well he found collins again
that's enough for brett brown who is not
at
all happy at the top of the program keep
that man out of the painted area
it leads to good things and and staying
the course to finish games
and you know that's been our achilles
heel i think we've played some very good
teams
and some not so good teams
by j.c now we've done a better job
of of just protecting the rim like you
see jc here
trey doubled reddish
alex lynn back off the glass collins up
high to flake it down
there you go big fella john collins john
collins
off the missed shot there by lynn he
goes way upstairs to throw it down over
andre drummond
bert times has it stolen by hunter over
to herder
kevin pulls the three ball
[Applause]
in the arena because of the plays of
john collins of course he's the
energizer
see if we can get this ball into trey's
hands no
kevin to collins he'll launch it and
back it in john collins
and tice was all over him kevin hurder
gives him the basketball look at ty's
come up to defend
and collins off the glass
sweet what a shot oh this is going to
give kelsey and stinger lots
to talk about trade moves in
herder cuts back door shovels oh my
goodness
that's what i'm talking about with
authority oh this john collins dunk
i mean this was just vicious
reddish goodness
and the hawks trailer the cavaliers 23
to 16. look at that one-hander by
john collins you might think it's
washington
trey shoots an air ball hunter saves it
but into the hands of fournier
and the magic have numbers and as with
only college back he missed the jam and
college challenged it perfectly
nice block there again john collins
field comes to help herbert with the
steal boy that was a poor pass by napier
disappointed with the second foul but
loving this one check out this dunk
by j.c john the baptist it's going to
work in dc
[Music]
boy the hawks just can't get it going
from the outside here quickly to knox he
explodes
and a challenge and a block by john
collins great block there by john
collins
getting back to deny check this out
oh man you talking about time oh man i
mean that was
all ball
[Applause]
once he got past peyton see you i like
it
that's the 10. zach from the wing
trey the rebound well you talked about
the hawks wanting to play better d
collins on the jam makes it 16-9
picture perfect lob it's just a thing of
beauty there you know your big guys
you're gonna get out and run you're
gonna get rewarded for john collins is
his biggest target
11 rebounds six dimes and 12 points
that's a solid all-around game about
that john collins
yes sir on the out of bounds play john
passes it in
comes off the trey screen and hello
goodbye
oh man it's just a thing of beauty
you think it's that coming home jitters
for you how was it
yeah coming back home to play for your
first time yeah you want you i think you
end up doing whoa
john collins goes upstairs kevin heard a
great pass there's
one impressive one-hander here yeah
kevin herder
he said hey if i throw it up there grant
trying to come and get it
and does jeremy grant against collins
drives in gets to the basket blocked by
college we're going to overtime
a drive by grant and that baby had no
chance
john collins all over it
and it's just a heck of a defensive play
oh john collins did not give he got beat
off the dribble but
stayed with it wow
shot that with confidence though bob
tail shooting oh nice pass
block jc with a reverse nice pass again
took it right to the chest to capela 13
for barton tonight on the lob to jc and
he one hands it
john collins just gets out on the break
and throws that one down with authority
about teams you know tuning up for the
playoffs how many games did you think it
would take
to get your razor shot for the
postseason well you know
oh johnny johnny go upstairs and gets it
nice play there here's that last dunk by
john this was nasty
that's the john collins we know and love
let's throw it up and let him go
upstairs and get it
holiday acquired in the deal from new
orleans
collins
[Music]
g.a they need some secondary consistent
sources of scoring tonight
and uh john collins can certainly fit
that bill
yeah that was a terrific pass there by
herta
and uh now t.j mcconnell floats it down
it's poked away by collins from behind
hawks get it back ahead to herder lob to
collins hill one-handed
and it's 122-119 he just went off over
levert
and once john gets up here nothing much
you can do
that's a wonderful pass by kevin
and westbrook has his sixth rebound
needs four more
up ahead hachimura and he gets it pinned
by collins
this is collins just getting up
quick he's got to be uh
one of the most sought after free agents
this year and right now they've got an
11 point lead
with under three left in the quarter
here comes barrett down the paint
turned back by collins they throw it
into the backcourt for trey young
[Applause]
their surest ball handler throws it up
and that is
the exclamation point john collins with
that smoke
to say good night the pass i'll just
watch as they come in there
see he embiid was right there now
he thought he was fouled on the play
here comes young
looking for his first basket of the
quarter flops
oh college with one hand on top of him
[Applause]
this is just a great pass but a terrific
athletic
move any time that you can devote over
a seven foot guy at 280 pounds this is a
great
jumping how about the catch and then
the slam through basically
that was a pass too that was not a shot
there
by trey young wow touched by capella
it'll be
fox ball young knew that collins was
going to roll
hard all along so he threw this above
the square
and let the athleticism of collins do
the rest
that is a beautiful play there by young